the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
great so last week or last few lectures
you heard about parallel architectures
and started with lecture 4 on
discussions of concurrency how do you
take applications or independent actors
that want to operate on the same data
and make them run safely together and so
just recapping the last two lectures you
saw are really two primary classes of
architectures although saman talked
about a few more there was the class of
shared memory processors you know the
multi-core is that Intel and AMD and
PowerPC for example have today where you
have one copy of the data and that's
really shared among all the different
processors because they essentially
share the same memory and you have
things like or you need things like atom
a city and synchronization to be able to
make sure that the sharing is done
properly so that you don't get in to
rate at data rate situations where
multiple processors try to update the
same data element and you end up with
the erroneous results you also heard
about distributed memory processors so
an example of that might be the cell
loosely said where you have cores that
primarily access their own local memory
and if they while you can have a single
global memory address space to get data
from memory you essentially have to
communicate with the different
processors to explicitly fetch data in
and out so things like data distribution
where the data is and what you
communicate some patterns like affect
your performance
so what I'm going to talk about in
today's lecture is programming these two
different kinds of architectures shared
memory processors and distributed memory
processors and present you with some
concepts for commonly programming these
machines so in shared memory processors
you have say n processors 110 and
they're connecting it to a single memory
and if one processor asks for the value
stored at address X everybody knows
where it'll go look because there's only
one address X and so you can communicate
so different processors can communicate
through shared variables and you need
things like locking as I mentioned to
avoid race conditions or erroneous
computation so this example
parallelization you know straightforward
paralyzation in a shared memory machine
would be you have the simple loop that's
just running through an array and you're
adding elements of array a to elements
of array B and you're going to write
them to some new array C well if I gave
you this loop you can probably recognize
that there's really no data dependencies
here I can split up this loop into three
chunks let's say I have 3 processors
where one processor does all the
computations for iterations 1 through 0
through 3 sort of first for iterations
second processor does the next word
iterations and a third processor does
the last word integrations I say that's
shown on with the little short laser
pointer so that's shown here and what
you might need to do is some mechanism
to essentially tell the different
processors here's the code that you need
to run and maybe where to start and then
you may need some way of sort of
synchronizing these different processors
that say I'm done I can move on to the
next computation steps so this is an
example of a data parallel computation
loop has no real dependencies and you
know each processor can operate on
different data sets and what you can do
is you can have a process this is a
single application that that Forks off
or creates what are commonly called the
threads and each thread goes on executes
in this case the same computation so a
single process can create multiple
concurrent threads
and really each threat is just a
mechanism for encapsulating some some
trace of execution some execution path
so in this case you're essentially
capsule ating this particular loop here
and maybe you parameterize your start
index your and your ending index or
maybe your iteration balance your loop
bounds and in a shared memory processor
since you're communicating since there
is only a single memory really they can
you don't need to do anything special
about the data in this in this
particular example because everybody
knows where to go look for it everybody
can access it everything's independent
there's no real issues with races or
deadlocks so I just wrote down some
actual code for that loop that paralyze
it using pthreads commonly used
threading mechanism just to give you a
little bit flavor for you know the
complexity of the simple loop that we
had expands to a lot more code in this
case so you have your array it has 12
elements a b and c and you have the
basic function so this is the actual
code or computation that we want to
carry out and what i've done here is
i've parameterize where u is essentially
starting any array so you get this
parameter and then you calculate for
iterations worth and this is the
essentially competition that we're
carrying out and now in my main
programmer in my main function rather
what I do is I have this concept of
threads that I'm going to create in this
case I'm going to create three of them
there are some parameters that have to
pass in so some attributes which I'm now
going to get into here but then I pass
in the function pointer this is
essentially mechanism that says once
I've created the thread I go to this
function and execute this particular
code and then some arguments that are
functions so here I'm just passing an
index at which each loops which start
with and after I've created each thread
here implicitly in the thread creation
the code can just immediately starts
running and then once all the threads
have started running I can essentially
just exit the program because I've
completed
so what I've shown you is that first
example was a concept of or an example
of data parallelism so you performing
the same computation but instead of
operating on one big chunk of data
I've partitioned the data into smaller
chunks and I'll pass it on to I've
replicated computation so that I can get
that kind of parallelism but you can
there's another form of parallelism
called Control parallelism which
essentially use the same model of
threading but doesn't necessarily have
to run the same function or run the same
computation a thread so I've sort of
illustrated that in the in the
illustration there where these are your
data parallel computations and these are
some other computations in your code
okay so there's sort of a programming
model that allows you to do this kind of
parallelism with and tries to a sort of
help the programmer by taking their
sequential code and then adding
annotations that say this loop is data
parallel or this set of code is tasks
that has this kind of control
parallelism in it so you start with your
parallel code this is the same program
multiple data kind of parallelization so
you might have seen in the previous talk
and previous lecture it was sim D single
instruction or same instruction multiple
data which allowed you to execute the
same operation you don't add over
multiple data elements so here it's a
similar kind of terminology there's a
same program multiple data and multiple
programs in optical data this talk is
largely focused on the SPMD model where
you essentially have one central
decision-maker or you're trying to solve
one central computation and you're
trying to paralyze that over your
architecture to get the best performance
so you start off with your program and
then you annotate the code with what's
parallel and what's not parallel and you
might add in some synchronization
directives so that if you do in fact
have sharing you might want to use the
right locking mechanism to guarantee
safety now in OpenMP there are some
limitations as to what it can do so it
in fact assumed
that the programmer knows what he's
doing and the programmer is largely
responsible for getting the
synchronization right or that if they're
sharing that they get those dependencies
protected correctly so you can take your
program in Serkis annotations and then
you go on and test and debug so a simple
OpenMP example again using the simple
loop now I've thrown away some of the
extra code you add in these two extra
pragmas in this case the first one you
know parallel pragma I call the data
parallel pragma really says that you can
execute as many of the following code or
the following code block as there are
processors or as many as you have thread
context so in this case I have
implicitly made the assumption that I
have three processors so you can
automatically partition my code into
three sets this transformation sort of
be done automatically by the compiler
and then there's a four pragma that says
this loop is parallel and you can divide
up the work in in a mechanism that's
work sharing so multiple threads can
collaborate to solve the same
computation but each one does a smaller
amount of work
so this is in contrast to where I'm
going to focus on a lot more in your
theater talk which is distributed memory
processors and programming for
distributed memories and this will feel
a lot more like programming for the cell
as you get more and more involved in
that and your projects get more intense
so in a distributed memory processor 2
to recap the previous lectures you have
n processors each processor has its own
memory and they essentially share the
interconnection network so you have each
processor has its own address X so when
a processor p1 asks for X it knows where
your logo look it's going to look in its
own local memory so if all processors
are asking for the same address or for
the same value that store to address X
and each one goes and looks in a
different place so their end places to
look really and what's stored in those
addresses will vary because it's
everybody's local memory so if one
processor say p1 wants to look at the
value stored in processor twos address
it actually has to explicitly request it
the processor 2 has to send it at data
and processor 1 has to figure out you
know what to do with that copy so it has
to store it somewhere so this message
passing really uses exposes explicit
communication to exchange data and
you'll see that there there's different
kinds of data communications but really
the concept of what you exchange has 3
different or 4 different rather things
you to address one is what is it how is
the data described and what does it
describe how are the processes
identified so how do I identify that
processor one is sending me this data
and if I'm receiving data how do I know
who I'm receiving it from does are all
messages the same well you know if I
send a message to somebody do I have any
guarantees that it's received or not and
what does it mean for a send operation
or receive operation to be completed you
know is there some sort of
acknowledgement process
so an example of a message processing
program and if you've started to look at
the lab you'll see that this is
essentially dia this is where the lab
came from or the - and it's the same
idea I've created here I have some
two-dimensional space and I have points
in this two-dimensional space I have
points B which are these blue circles
and I have a point a which I've
represented as these yellow or golden
squares and what I want to do is for
every point in a I want to calculate the
distance to all other points B so
there's sort of a pairwise interaction
between the two arrays so a simple loop
that essentially does this you know and
their inspirations right now oh yeah and
squared interactions you have you know a
loop that loops over all the elements
loop that loops over all the B elements
and you essentially calculate in this
case your cluding and distance which I'm
not showing and you store it into some
new array so if I give you two
processors to do this work processor 1
and processor 2 and I give you some
mechanism to share between the two so
here's my CPU here's each processors
local memory where we sum approach for
actually paralyzing this anybody you
look at the lab yet okay so what would
you do with two processors
right so you split so all the sizes that
you split one of the arrays and two and
you can actually get that kind of
concurrency so you know let's say
processor one already has data and it
has some place that it's already
allocated where it's going to right see
the results of the computation then I
can break up the work just like it was
suggested so what p1 has to do is send
data to p2 it says here's the data
here's the computation go ahead and help
me out so I send the first array
elements and then I send half of the
other elements that I want to edit the
calculations done for and then p1 and p2
can now sort of start computing in
parallel but notice that he too has its
own array that's going through store
results in and so as these compute they
actually fill in different logical
places or logical parts of overall
matrix so what has to be done is at the
end for P want to have all the results
p2 has ascending through the rest of the
matrix to complete it and so now p1 has
all the results the computation is done
and you can move on that makes sense ok
so you'll get to actually do this as
part of your lives so in there in this
example messaging program you have
started out with a sequential code and
we had two processors so processor one
actually sends the code so it is
essentially template for the code you'll
end up writing and it does have to work
in the outer loop so this inner rate
over which was iterating the a array is
it's only doing half as many and
processor 2 has actually received the
data and it specifies where to receive
the data into so I admitted some things
for example as to or extra information
sort of hidden in these parameters so
here you're sending all of a all of B
whereas you know you could have
specified extra parameters that says you
know I'm sending you a here's n elements
to read from a here's B here's and by
two elements read from B and so on
but the computation is essentially the
same except for the index at which you
start in this case I've changed for
processor two and now when the
computations done this guy essentially
waits until the data is received
processor to eventually sends it that
data and now you can move on yeah
yes there's a I'll get into that later
so just receive you know what does it
mean to receive can I you know to do
this computation and I actually need
this completion this instruction to
complete so what does it mean for that
instruction to complete I do have to get
the data because otherwise I don't know
what to compute on so there's some
synchronization implicit synchronization
that you have to do in some cases it's
six plus it so I'll get into that a
little bit later does that sort of hint
at the answer are you so confused so so
in terms of tracing right processor one
sense of data and then can immediately
start executing it's good right
processor two has to wait until in this
particular example has to wait until it
receives the data so once this receive
completes then you can actually go and
start executing the rest of the code
right so imagine that there's a
essentially says wait until I have data
wait until have something to do
and you'll see they're an example
because the the PPE in that case has to
send the data to do different SPE s yep
be convenient since then if you have
huge array and you want to start up
speaking before you receive the whole
array then you have everything is yeah
we'll get into that later yeah yeah I
mean that's a good point you know
communication is not cheap and if you
sort of don't take that into
consideration you end up paying a lot
for it overhead for paralyzing things
well you can do things in software as
well I'll get into them okay so some
good performance analysis so I have to
calculate this distance and given to
processors I can effectively get a 2x
speed-up by dividing up the work I can
get done in in half the time well if you
gave me four processors I can maybe get
done four times as fast and in my
communication model here I have one copy
of one array that's I'm essentially
sending to every processor and there's
some subset of a so I'm partitioning my
other array into smaller subsets and I'm
sending those to each of the different
processors so we'll get into terminology
for how to actually name these
communications later but really the
thing to take away here is that this
granularity how I'm partitioning a
affects my performance and communication
almost directly and you know the comment
that was just made is that you know what
do you do at communication it's not free
so all of those
we'll be addressed so to understand
performance we sort of summarize three
main concepts that you essentially need
to understand one is coverage or in
other words how much parallelism there
actually have in my application so and
this can actually affect you know how
much work is it worth spending on in
this particular application granularity
you know how do you partition your data
among the different processors so that
you can keep communication down so you
can keep synchronization down and so on
locality so while not shown in a
particular example if two processors are
communicating if they are a closed in
space or foreign space or if the
communication between two processors is
far cheaper than two other processors
can i exploit that in some way and so
we'll talk about that as well so an
example of sort of parallelism in an
application there are two essentially
projects they're doing rate tracing so I
thought I'd have this slide here you
know how much parallelism do you have in
in in a ray tracing program some trace
tracing what you do is essentially have
some camera sources some some observer
and you're trying to figure out you know
how to color or how to shade different
pixels in your screen three Drew's you
shoot rays from a particular source
through your plane and then you see how
to raise bounce off of other objects and
that allows you to Rend your scenes in
various ways so you have different kinds
of parallelism you have your primary
array that's shot in and if you're
shooting into something like water or
some very reflective surface or some
surface stick and actually reflect
transmit and whoops you can essentially
end up with a lot more rays that are
created at one time right so there's
dynamic parallelism in this particular
example and you can shoot a lot of rays
from here so there's different kinds of
parallelism you can exploit
not all prior programs have this kind of
sort of a lot of parallelism or
embarrassingly parallel computation
there you know you saw some basic code
sequences in earlier lectures so there's
a sequential part and reason this is
sequential is because there are dataflow
dependencies between each of the
different computations so here I
calculate a but I need the result of a
to do this instruction I calculate D
here and I need a result to calculate e
but then this loop really here is just
assigning or it's initializing some big
array and I can really do that in
parallel so I have sequential parts and
parallel parts so how does that affect
my overall speed ups and so there's this
law which is really a demonstration of
diminishing returns a Modell's law it
says that if you know you have a really
fast car it's only as good as to do as
fast as you can drive it so if there's a
lot of congestion on your road or you
know there are posted speed limits or
some other mechanisms
you really can't exploit all the speed
of your car or in other words you only
as fast as have the fastest mechanisms
of computation that you can have so to
look at this in sort more detail your
potential speed up is really
proportional to the fraction of the code
that can be paralyzed so if I have some
computation let's say it has three parts
a sequential part that takes 25 seconds
a parallel park takes 50 seconds and a
sequential part that runs 25 in 25
seconds so a total execution time is 100
seconds and if I have one processor
that's really all I can do but if you
give me more than one processor so let's
say I have five processors well I can't
do anything about the sequential work so
that's still going to take 25 seconds
and I can't do anything about this
sequential work either that still take
25 seconds but this parallel part I can
essentially break up among the different
processors so five in this case and that
gets me you know five-way parallelism so
the 50 seconds now is reduced 10 seconds
is that clear so far so overall running
time in that case is 60 seconds so what
would be my speed up well you calculate
speed up
all running time divided by the new
running time so 100 seconds divided by
60 seconds or my parallel version is one
point six seven times faster so this is
great
if I increase the number of processors
then that should be able to get more and
more parallelism there also means that
there's a sort of an upper bound on how
much speed up you can get so if you look
at the fraction of work in your
application that's parallel and that's P
and your number of processors well your
speed-up is let's say at all running
times just one unit of work it's the
time it takes for the sequential work so
it's 1 minus P since P is the fraction
of the apparel work and it's the time to
do the parallel work and since I can
paralyze that fraction over n processors
I can sort of reduce that to a really
small amounts in the limit does that
make sense offer
so the speed-up can tend to one over one
minus P in the limit as I increase the
number of processors or that gets really
large that's that's essentially my upper
bound on how fast programs can work you
know how much can i exploit out of my
program so this is great what this law
says the implication here is if your
program has a lot of inherent
parallelism you can do really well but
if your program doesn't have any
parallelism well there's really nothing
you can do so parallel architectures
won't really help you and there's some
interesting trade-offs for example that
you might consider if you're designing a
chip or if you're looking at an
application or domain of applications
figuring out what is the best
architecture to run them on so in terms
of performance scalability as I increase
the number of processors
I have speed-up you can define sort of
an efficiency it to be a linear at a
hundred percent but typically you end up
in sort of the sublinear domain that's
because communication is not often free
and we you can get super linear speed-up
saan real architectures because of
secondary and tertiary effects that come
from register allocation or caching
effects so they can hide a lot of
latency or they can really you can take
advantage of a lot of pipelining
mechanisms in the architecture to get
super linear speed-up
so you can end up in really in two
different domains okay so a small you
know overview of the extent of
parallelism in your program and how that
affect your overall execution and the
other concept is granularity so given
that I have this much parallelism how do
i exploit it there are different ways of
exploiting it and that comes down to
well how do I subdivide my problem what
is the granularity of the subproblems
I'm going to calculate on
and really granularity from my
perspective this is just a qualitative
measure of what is the ratio of your
computation to your communication so if
you're doing a lot of computation very
little communication you could be doing
really well or vice versa then you could
be competition limited and so you need a
lot of bandwidth for example in your in
your architecture yeah yeah so and as
you saw in in their previous slides you
have computation stages are separated by
communication stages and communication
in a lot of cases essentially serves as
synchronization I need to I need
everybody to get to the same point
before I can move on logically in my
computation so there are two kinds of
sort of classes of granularity there's
fine grained and as you'll see coarse
grain
so in fine grained parallelism you have
low computation to communication ratio
and that has good properties in that you
have a small amount of work done between
communication stages and sorry it has
bad properties and that it gives you
less performance opportunity I should be
more more opportunity for fun sorry yes
sorry I didn't get enough sleep just in
times like creation so less
opportunities for performance
enhancement that you have a high
communication ratio because essentially
you're communicating very often so these
are the computations here and these
yellow bars are the synchronization
points so I have to distribute data or
communicate I do computations but you
know computation doesn't last very long
and I do more more communication or more
synchronization and I repeat the process
so naturally you can adjust the screen
Larry to sort of reduce the
communication overhead
that overhead path one is the volume
shows the amount of communication also
there's a large part of synchronization
they still get a communication going you
have to start the messages and we
innovate with everybody's done so that
overhead also can go even if you don't
send that much data
this is the fact that you are
communicating that means you are here to
a lot of this additional keeping stuff
that that specially in the distributable
machine is efficacious Thanks yeah so in
coarse grained parallelism you sort of
make the work chunks more and more so
that you do the communication and
synchronization less and less and so
that's shown here you do longer pieces
of work and have fewer synchronization
stages and so in this and that regime
that you can have more opportunities for
performance improvements but they think
the tricky thing that you get into is
what's called load balancing so if each
of these different computations take
differing amounts of time to complete
than what you might end up doing is a
lot of people might end up idle as they
wait until everybody's essentially
reached their finish line yeah
so you can do that in cases where that
essentially there's a mechanism where
the application allows for it but as
I'll show well you won't see until the
next lecture there are dependencies for
example that might preclude you from
doing that if everybody needs to reach
the same point because you're updating a
large data structure before you can go
on then you might not be able to do that
so I think of updating doing molecular
dynamics simulations you need everybody
to calculate a new position before you
can go on and calculate new kinds of
force interactions yeah because
communication is such a intensive cart
there three there are different ways of
dealing with it and that'll be right
after a load balancing so the load
balancing problems just an illustration
and things that appear in sort of this
sliders pink will harp it will serve as
sort of visual cues this is the same
color coding scheme that David's using
in the recitations so this is ppyou code
things that appear in yellow will be SPU
code and these are just meant to
essentially show you how you might do
things like this on cell just to help
you along in picking up more of these
syntax and functionality you need to for
your program so in in the load balancing
problem you essentially have let's say
three different threads of three
different threads of computation and so
that's shown here red blue and orange
and you've reached some communication
stage so the PPU program in this case is
saying send a message to each of my SPE
s to each my different processors that
you're ready to start and so now once
every every processor gets that message
they can start computing in let's assume
they have data and so on ready to go and
what's going to happen is each processor
is going to run through the computation
at different rates
now this could be because one processor
is faster than another or it could be
because one processor is more loaded
than another or it could be just because
each processor is assign sort of less
differing amounts of work so one has a
short loop one has a longer loop
and so as the animation shows to have
execution proceeds and everybody's
waiting until the orange guy has
completed but nobody could have made
progress until everybody's reached a
synchronization point because you know
there's a strict dependence that's being
enforced here that says I'm going to
wait until everybody's told me they're
done before I go on to the next step of
computation and so that's you know until
you do that using mailboxes in this case
that clear server okay so how do you get
around this load balancing problem well
there are two different ways there's
static load balancing I know my
application really really well and I
understand sort of different
computations so what I can do is I can
divide up the work and have a static
mapping of the work to my processors and
static mapping just means yeah as you
know in this particular example that I'm
going to assign to work different
processors and that's what the
processors will do where can't shift
around between processors and so in this
case I have work you each of those bars
is some computation and I can assign
some chunk to P 1 processor 1 some chunk
to processor 2 and then computation can
go on those those allocations don't
change so this works well if I
understand the application while I know
what the computation and my cores are
relatively homogeneous and you know not
there's not a lot of contention for them
so if all the cores are the same each
court has equal amount of work total
amount of work this works really well
because nobody is sitting to trial
doesn't work so well for heterogeneous
architectures or a multi-course because
one might be faster than the other it
increases the complexity of the
allocation I need to do if there's a lot
of contention for some resources then
that can affect my static load balancing
so work distribution might end up being
uneven so the alternative is dynamic
load balancing and you certainly could
do a sort of a hybrid load balancing
static + dynamic mechanism I don't have
that in the slides so in the nine amick
load balancing scheme two differents do
two different mechanisms I'm going to
straight so in the first game you start
with something like the static mechanism
so I have some work going to processor 1
and I have some work going to processor
2
but then as processor to execute and
gets a complete say fast and processor
wants some of the work it takes on some
of the additional work from processor 1
so the work that was here is now shifted
and so you can keep helping out you know
your other processors to compute things
faster in the other scheme you have a
work queue where you essentially are
distributing work on the fly so as
things complete you're just sending in
sending them more work to do so in this
animation you know I started office and
work to do different processors v2 is
really faster it's just zipping through
things and then p1 eventually finishes
and a new work is allocated to to the
two different schemes so dynamic load
balancing is just intended to sort of
give equal amounts of work in a
different scheme for processors so you
really increased utilization and spend
less and less time being idle ok so load
balancing was one part of sort of higher
granularity can have a performance
straight off the other synchronization
so there were already some good
questions as to well you know how does
this play into overall execution when
can I wait one can't I wait so I'm going
to illustrate it with just a simple data
dependence graph although you can
imagine that in each one of these
circles there's some really heavy load
computation and you'll see that in the
next lecture in fact so if I have some
simple computation here I have some
operands doing an addition here I do
another addition I need both of these
results before I can do this
multiplication here I have you know some
loop that's adding through some array
elements I need all those results before
I do a final subtraction and produce my
final result so what are some
synchronization points here well really
depends on how I allocate these
different instructions to processors so
if I have an allocation that you says
well let's put all these chains on one
processor put these two chains on two
different processors well where are my
synchronization points well depends on
where this guy is
and we're disguise
because for this instruction to execute
it needs to receive data from P 1 and P
2 so if P 1 and P 2 are different from
what's in that box
somebody has to wait and so there's a
synchronization that has to happen so I
can get rid of that synchronous it so
essentially all joint points there's
potential first synchronization but I
can adjust a granularity so that I can
remove more and more synchronization
points and so you know oops
let's rip in the enemy so if I had to
sign all this this entire sub graph to
the same processor I really get rid of
the synchronization because it's
essentially local to that particular
processor and there's no extra messaging
it has to happen across processors that
says I'm ready or I'm ready to send you
data or you can move on to the next step
and so in this case the last
synchronization point would be at this
strong point let's say if it's allocated
on P 1 or on some other processor so how
would I get rid of this synchronization
point
right you you put the entire thing on a
single processor but you get no
parallelism in this case right so the
coarse grain fine grained parallelism
granularity issue comes to play so the
last sort of thing I'm going to talk
about in terms of how granularity
impacts performance and this was already
touched on is that communication is
really not cheap and can be quite
overwhelming on a lot of architectures
and what's interesting about multicores
is that they're essentially putting a
lot more resources closer together on a
chip
so essentially changing its changing the
factors for communication so rather than
having you know your parallel cluster
now which is connected say by Ethernet
or some other high-speed link now you
essentially have large clusters or will
have large clusters on a chip so
communication factors really change but
the cost model is relatively captured or
by these different parameters so what
does it actually take me or what is the
cost of my communication well it's equal
to well how many messages am i sending
and what is the frequency with which I'm
sending them there's some overhead for a
message so I have to actually package
data together I have to stick in a
control header and then send it out so
that takes me some work on the receiver
side have to take the message out maybe
I have to decode the header figure out
where to store things where distorted
data is coming in on the message so
there's some overhead associated with
that as well
there's a network delay for sending a
message so putting thing putting a
message on the network so that it can be
transmitted or picking things up off the
network so there's a lane C also
associated with how long does it take
for a message to get from point A to
point B what is the bandwidth that I
have across a link so if I have a lot of
bandwidth then that can really lower my
communication cost but if I have little
bandwidth and they could really create
contention how much data am i sending
and you know number of messages so this
numerator here is really an average of
the data you're sending per
communication
there's a cost induced per contention
and then finally there's so all of these
are out of the factors that the the
higher they are except for bandwidth
because it's in the denominator here the
worse your communication cost becomes so
you can try to reduce the communication
cost by communicating the less so you
adjust your granularity and that can
impact your synchronization over what
kind of data you're shipping around you
can do some architectural tweaks or
maybe some software tweaks to really get
the network latency down and the
overhead per message down so on
something like the raw architecture
which you saw in Simon's lecture there's
a really fast mechanism to communicate
nearest neighbor and three cycles so one
processor can send a single opera into
another reasonably fast you know you can
improve the bandwidth so again an
architectural mechanism you can do some
tricks as to how you package your data
in each message and lastly what I'm
going to talk about in in a couple of
slides is well I can also improve it
using some mechanisms that try to
increase overlap between messages and
what does this really mean what am i
overlapping it with and it's really the
communication and computation stages are
going to somehow get aligned so before I
can show you that I just want to point
out that there are two kinds of messages
there's data messages and these are for
example the arrays that I'm sending
around to different processors for that
distance calculations between points in
space but there are also control
messages so control messages essentially
say I'm done or I'm ready to go or
Azarian and you work for me to do so on
cell control messages you know you can
think of using mailboxes for those and
the DMAs for doing the data
communication so data messages are
relatively much larger you're sending a
lot of data versus control messages that
are really much shorter just essentially
you're just sending very brief
information okay so in order to get that
overlap what you can do is essentially
use this concept of pipelining
so you've seen pipelining a superscalar
someone talked about that and what
you're essentially trying to do is break
up the communication and
computation in two different stages and
then figure out a way to overlap them so
that you can essentially hide the
latency for for the sense and and
receives so let's say you have some work
that you're doing and really requires
you to send the data or get it for
somebody has to send you the data or you
have you essentially have to wait until
you get it and then after you've waited
and the data is there you can actually
go on and do your work
so these are color coded so this is
essentially one iteration of the work
and so you can overlap them by breaking
up the work in to send weight work
stages where each iteration trying to
send or request the data for the next
iteration I weight on the data from a
previous iteration and then I do my work
so depending on how I partition I can
really get really good overlap and so
what you want to get to is the concept
of the steady state where in your main
loop body all you're doing is
essentially prefetching or requesting
data it's going to be used in future
iterations for future work and then you
you're waiting on yeah I think oh
there's little bits good okay so here's
an example of how you might do this kind
of buffer pipelining itself so I have
some main loop that's going to do some
work that's encapsulate in this process
data and what I'm gonna use is two
buffers so the scheme is also called
double buffering I'm going to use this
ID to represent which buffer I'm going
to use so it's either zero buffer zero
or buffer 1 and this instruction here
essentially flips the bid so it's either
0 or 1 so I fetch data into buffer 0 and
then I enter my loop so this is
essentially the first send which is
trying to get me one iteration ahead so
I entered this mail loop and I do some
calculation to figure out where to write
the next data and then I do another
request for the next data item then I'm
going to sorry there's an M missing here
just notice that I'm going to fetch data
into a different buffer right this is ID
where I've already flipped a bit once so
this
get is going to write data into buffer
zero and this gate is going to write
data into buffer one I flipped a bit
again so now I'm going to issue a weight
instruction that says has the data from
buffer zero is the data from buffer zero
already and if it is then I can go on
and actually do my work that makes sense
people confused I go over it again okay
so this is an XOR so I could have just
said buffer equals zero or buffer equals
one so this is a one here and last night
hitting did that confuse you here is
going to write into ID 0 so that's
buffer buffer zero right and then I'm
going to change the ID so imagine
there's a 1 here so now the next next
time I use ID which is here I'm trying
to get the data and I'm going to write
it to buffer 1 the DMA on the Cell
processor essentially says I can send
this request off and I can check later
to see when that data is available but
that data is going to go into a
different buffer essentially B 1 whereas
I'm going to work on buffer 0 right
because I change the ID back here now
you get so I fetch data into buffer 0
initially before I start to loop and
then I start working I probably should
have had an animation in here so then
you go into you go into your main loop
use you try to start fetching into
buffer 1 and then you try to compute out
of buffer 0 but before you can start
computing out of buffer 0 you just have
to make sure that your data is there and
so that's what the synchronization is
doing here
hope that was clear okay so this kind of
computation and communication overlap
really helps in hiding the latency and
it can be really useful in terms of
improving performance and there are
different kinds of communication
patterns
so there's point-to-point and you can
use these both for data communication or
control communication and just means
that you know one processor can
explicitly send a message to another
processor there's also a broadcast that
says hey I have some data everybody's
interested in so I can just broadcast it
to everybody on the network or reduce
which is the opposite that says
everybody on the network has data that I
need to compute so everybody send me
their data there's an all-too all which
as all processors should just do a
global exchange of data that they have
and then there's a scatter and a gather
so scattering together are really
different types of broadcasts so it's
one to several or one-to-many and gather
which is many to one so this is useful
when you're doing computation that
really is trying to pull data in
together but only from a subset of all
processors so it depends on how you've
partitioned your your problems so
there's a well-known sort of message
passing library specification called MPI
that tries to essentially implement that
it tries to specify all of these
different communications and in in order
to sort of facilitate parallel
programming
it's full-featured actually has more
types of communications and more kind of
functionality than I showed on the
previous slides but it's not a language
or compiler specification it's really
just a library that you can implement in
various ways on different architectures
again it's a same program multiple data
or supports the SPMD model and it works
really well for parallel architectures
for clusters heterogeneous and
multicores homogeneous multicores
because really all it's doing is just
abstracting out well
it's giving you a mekin
to abstract out all the communication
that you would need in your computation
so you can have additional things like
precise buffer management you can have
some collective operations I'll show you
an example of four for doing things in a
scalable matter when you're a computer
things need to communicate with each
other so just a brief history of where
MPI came from and you know very early
when you know parallel computers started
becoming more and more widespread than
they were these networks and people had
problems porting their applications or
writing applications for these King just
because it was difficult as you might be
finding in in terms of programming
things with the Cell processor you know
there needed to be ways to sort of
address the spectrum of communication
and it often helps to have a standard
because if everybody implements the same
standard specification that allows you
code to be ported around from one
architecture to the other and so MPI
came around
the forum was for forum was organized
1992 and they had a lot of people
participating in it from vendors you
like IBM company like IBM Intel and
people who were interested in or who had
expertise and writing libraries users
who are interested in using these kinds
of specification to to do their
computations so scientific people who
are in the scientific domain and it was
finished in about eighteen months I
don't know if that's a reasonably long
time or a short time but considering I
think the mpeg-4 standard took a bit
longer to do is that a comparison point
I don't have the actual data so a
point-to-point communication and again a
reminder this is how you would do it on
cell these are SPE sends and receives
you have one processor that's sending
there to another processor and you have
some network in between a processor a
can essentially send the data explicitly
to processor two and the message in this
case would include how data is packaged
some other information such as the
length of the data destination possibly
some
so you can identify the actual
communication and you know there's a
mapping natural mapping for for the
actual functions on cell and there's a
get for the send and a put for your
thief okay so it was a question of well
how do I know if my data actually got
sent how do I know who's received and
there's a you know you can think of a
synchronous send and a synchronous
receive or asynchronous communication so
in the synchronous communication you
actually wait for a notification so this
is kind of like your fax machine and you
put something into your fax it goes out
and you eventually get a beep that says
your transmission is okay or if it
wasn't okay then you know you get a
message that says you know something
went wrong and you can redo your
communication the asynchronous sent it's
kind of like you yeah you can get a
reply Thanks an asynchronous send it's
like you write a letter you go put in
the mailbox and you don't know whether
it actually made it into into the actual
post man's bag and it was delivered to
your destination or or if it was
actually delivered so you only know that
the message was sent you know you put it
in the mailbox but you don't know
anything else about what happened to the
message along the way there's also the
concept of a blocking versus of non
blocking message so this is orthogonal
really to synchronous versus
asynchronous so in blocking messages
send their waits until there's some
signal that says the message has been
transmitted so this is for example if
I'm writing data into a buffer that and
the buffer essentially gets transmitted
to somebody else well you wait until the
buffer is empty and what that means is
that somebody has read it on the other
end or somebody has drained that buffer
from somewhere else the receiver if he's
waiting on data well he just waits he
essentially blocks until somebody has
put data into the buffer and you can get
into potential deadlock situations so
you saw a deadlock with locks in the
concurrency talk I'm going to show you a
different kind of deadlock example
an example of a blocking send on on cell
allows you to use mailboxes or you can
sort of use mailboxes for that mailboxes
again are just for communicating short
messages really not necessarily for
communicating data messages so an SPE
does some work and then right side a
message in this case is to notify the
PPU that let's say it's done and then it
goes on it does more work and then it
wants to notify the PPU of something
else so in this case this particular
send will block because let's say the
PPU hasn't drained this mailbox it
hasn't read the mailbox so essentially
stop and wait until the PPU has has you
know caught up yes david says yes
a non-blocking send is something that
essentially allows you to send a message
out and just continue on you don't care
exactly about what what's happened to
the message or what's going on with the
receiver so you write the data into into
the buffer and just continue executing
and this really helps you in terms of
avoiding idle times and deadlocks but it
might not always be the thing that you
want so an example of sort of a
non-blocking send and wait on cell is
using the DMA s to ship data out you
know you can put something I put in a
request to send data out on the DMA and
you could wait for it if you want in
terms of making sure that reading the
status bits to make sure it's completed
okay so what is the source of deadlock
in the blocking case and it really comes
about if you don't really have enough
buffering in your communication network
and often you can resolve that by having
additional storage so let's say I have
process for one the processor too and
they're trying to send messages to each
other so processor one sends a message
at the same time processor two sends a
message and these are going are going to
go let's say into the same buffer well
either can make progress because
somebody has to essentially drain that
buffer before these receives can execute
so what happens with that codes it
really depends on how much buffering you
have between the two if you have a lot
of buffering then you may never see sort
of the deadlock but if there's a lot of
if you have a really tiny buffer then
you you do ascend the other person can't
do to send because they are the buffer
hasn't been drained and so you end up
with a deadlock and so a potential
solution is well you actually increase
your buffer length but that doesn't
always work because you can still get
into trouble so what you might need to
do is essentially be more diligent about
how you order your sends and receives so
if you have processor one doing send
make sure it's matched up with a receive
on the other end and similarly if you're
doing the receive here make sure there's
sort of a matching send on the other end
and that helps you in sort of making
sure that things are operating
reasonably in lockstep at you know
partially ordered times
broadcast mechanism so I showed you
those really examples of point-to-point
communication a broadcast mechanism is
slightly different it says I have data
that I want to send to everybody it
could be really efficient for sending
short control messages maybe even
efficient for sending data messages so
as an example if you remember our
calculation of distances between all
points the parallelization strategy you
said well I'm going to send one copy of
the array a to everybody so in the two
processor case that was easy but if I
have n processors then rather than
sending point-to-point communication
from A to everybody else what I could do
is just say broadcast a to everybody and
they can grab it off the network so in
MPI there's this directive or this
function MPI broadcast that does that
I'm using sort of generic abstract sends
receives and broadcast in my examples so
you can broadcast a to everybody and
then if I have n processors then when I
might do is distribute the MS in a round
robin manner to each of the different
processors so you pointed this out I
don't have to send beat everybody I can
just send you know in this case one
particular element is that clear
all right
there is no broadcast on so there is no
mechanism for a reduction either and you
can't quite do scale that scatters and
gathers okay I don't think okay so an
example of a reduction you know I said
it's the opposite of a broadcast
everybody has data that needs to
essentially get to the same point so as
an example if everybody in this room had
a value and including myself and I
wanted to know what is the collective
value of everybody in the room you all
have to send me your data now this is
important because if you know in this
case we're doing in addition it's an
associative operation so what we can do
is we can be smart about how the data is
sent so you know guides that are close
together can essentially add up their
numbers and forward me so instead of
getting and messages I can get login
messages and so if every care of you
added your numbers and forwarded me that
that cuts down communication by half and
so you can you know starting from the
back of room by the time you get to me I
only get two messages instead of end
messages so a reduction combines data
from all processors in MPI it's you know
there's this function MPI reduce for
doing that and the collective operations
are things that are associative and
subtract sorry and or and you read the
month like no processor that there's a
semantic caveat here is that no
processor can finish the reduction
before all processors have at least sent
at one data or have contributed a rather
a particular value so in many numerical
algorithm algorithms you can actually
use the broadcast and send the broadcast
and reduce in in place of sends and
receives because it really helps to
improve the simplicity or it improves
the simplicity of your computation you
don't have to do n sends to communicate
you can just broadcast it gives you a
mechanism for essentially having a
shared memory abstraction on distributed
memory architecture there are things
like also all communication which also
help you in that sense although I don't
talk about also all communication here
so I'm going to show you an example of
sort of a more detailed MPI
and but I also want to contrast this to
the openmp programming on shared memory
processors because one might look
simpler than the other so suppose that
you have a numerical integration method
that's essentially you're going to use
to calculate pi so as you get finer and
finer you can get more accurate as you
shrink these intervals you can get
better values for pi and the code for
doing that and some C code you have some
variables and then you have a step that
essentially tells you how many times
you're going to do this computation and
for each time step you calculate this
particular function here and you add it
all up and in the end he can sort of
print out what is the value of pi that
you've calculated so clearly as you know
as you shrink your intervals you can get
more and more accurate measures of pi so
that translates to increasing the number
of steps in in that particular loop or
in that particular C code so you can
compute you can use that numerical
integration to calculate pi with openmp
and what that translates to is sorry I
should have an animation here ask you
what I should add in you have this
particularly and this is the computation
that you want to paralyze and there's
really four questions that you
essentially have to go through are there
variables that are shared because you
have to get the process right if there
are variables that are shared you have
to explicitly synchronize them and use
locks to protect them what values are
private to an open MP things that are
private are data on the stack things
that are defined lexically within the
scope of the computation that you
encapsulate by an open MP pragma and
what variables you might want to use for
a reduction so in this case you know
doing a summation and this is the
computation that I can paralyze then I
essentially want to do a reduction with
a plus operator since I'm doing an
addition on this variable this loop here
is parallel it's okay so data parallel I
can split it up it's the loop the for
loop is also
I can do this work sharing on it so I
use the parallel for pragma and the
variable X here is private it's defined
here but I can essentially give a
directive that says this is private you
can essentially rename it on each
processor its value won't have any
effect on the overall computation
because each computation will have its
own local copy okay
so computing PI with integration using
MPI takes up two slides you know I could
fill you on one slide but you can't see
it in the back so there's some
initialization in fact I think there's
only six basic MPI commands that you
need for computing three of them are
here and you'll see you know the others
are MPI send MPI receive and there's one
more that you'll see on the next slide
so there's some loop that says while I'm
not done keep-keep computing and what
you do is you broadcast and to all
different processors and is really your
time step how many things how many small
intervals of execution are you going to
do and you can go through do your
computation so now this MPI essentially
capsulate the computation over n
processors and then you get to an MPI
reduce command at some point that says
okay what what values that everybody
compute do the reduction on that write
that value into my MPI
now what happens here is there's
processor ID zero which I'm going to
consider to master so he's the one who's
going to actually print out the value so
the reduction essentially synchronizes
until everybody's communicated of value
to processor zero and then it can print
out to PI and then you can finalize
which actually make sure computation can
exit and you can go on and terminate
okay so last concept in terms of
understanding performance for
parallelism for parallelism is this
notion of locality and there's locality
in your communication and locality in
your computation so what do I mean by
that so in terms of communication if I
have some two operations and let's say
this is a picture or schematic of what
the raw chip the MIT watch it looks like
each one of these is the core there's
some network some basic computation
elements and if I have you know in
addition that feeds into a shift well I
can put the addition here and a shift
there but that means I have a really
long path that I need to go to in terms
of communicating that data value around
so the computation naturally should just
be closer together because that
decreases the latency that I need to
communicate so rather than doing that
mapping what I might want to do is just
go to somebody who is close to me and
available you can assume this
communication going into channel whereas
no help in there then you can scale
communication much better
there's also emissions of locality in
terms of memory accesses and these are
potentially also very important or more
important rather because of the lane C's
for accessing memory so if I have you
know this loop that's doing some
addition or some computation on array
and I distributed say over four
processors this is again let's assume I
data parallel loop so what I can do is
have a work sharing mechanism that says
this thread here will operate on the
first four indices this thread here will
operate on the next four indices and
next for the next four and then you
essentially get to join barrier and then
you can continue on if we consider how
the access patterns are going to be
generated for for this particular loop
well in the sequential case I'm
essentially generating them in sequence
so that allows me to exploit for example
on traditional cat or architecture a
notion of spatial locality if I look at
how things are organized in memory in a
sequential case I can perhaps fetch an
entire block at a time so I can fetch
all the elements of a zero to a three in
one shot I can fetch all the elements of
a four to a seven in one shot and that
allows me to essentially improve a
performance because I overlap
communication I'm predicting that once I
see a reference I'm going to use data
that's adjacent to it in space it's also
a notion of temporal locality that says
if I use some particular data element
I'm going to reuse it later on I'm not
showing that here but in the parallel
case what could happen is if each one of
these threads is requesting a different
data element and let's say execution
essentially proceeds you know all the
threads are requesting their data and at
the same time then all these requests
are going to end up going to the same
memory bank spread the first thread is
requesting a safai a subzero the next
thread is requesting a so for next
thread ace of eight next next right ace
12 and all of these happen to be in the
same memory bank so what that means is
you know there's a lot of contention for
that one memory bank and in effect I've
serialized the computation right
everybody see that and you know this can
be a problem in that you can essentially
serial fully serialize the computation
and that you you know there's contention
on the first bank intention on the
second bank and then contention on the
third bank and in contention on the
fourth bank and so I've done absolutely
nothing other than pay overhead for
parallelization I've made extra work for
myself coming creating a few threads
maybe I've done some extra work in terms
of synchronization so I'm fully serial
so what you want to do is actually
reorganize the way data is laid out in
memory so that you can effectively get
the benefit of parallelization so if you
have the data organized as is there you
can shuffle things around and then you
end up with a fully parallel or a layout
that's more amenable to full parallelism
because now each thread is going to a
different Bank and that essentially
gives you a four-way parallelism and so
you get their performance benefits
so there are different kinds of
considerations need to take into account
for shared memory architectures in terms
of how the design affects the memory
latency so in a uniform memory access
architecture every processor has as
either you can think of it as being
equidistant from memory or another way
it has the same access latency for
getting data from memory most shared
memory architectures are non-uniform 0
also known as Numa architecture so you
have physically partitioned memories and
the processors can have the same address
space but the placement of data affects
the performance because going to one
bank versus another can be faster or
slower so what kind of architectures
cell yeah
no guesses
right it's not a shared memory
architecture okay
so summary of parallel performance
factors so there's three things I tried
to cover coverage of vics you know
coverage or the extent of parallelism in
your application so you saw Emma dolls
law and actually gave you sort of a
model it said when is parallel when is
paralyzing application going to be
worthwhile it really boils down to how
much parallelism you actually have in
your particular algorithm if you're high
with them sequential then there's really
nothing you could do for parallel
programming for performance using
parallel architectures talked about
granularity of the data partitioning and
the granularity of the work distribution
now if you had really fine-grained
things versus really coarse grained
things how does that translate to
different communication costs and then
last thing I said was look Hallie so if
you have near neighbors talking that
that may be different than two things
that are further apart in space
communicating and there are some issues
in terms of the memory latency how you
actually can take advantage of that so
this really is a overview of sort of the
parallel programming concepts and the
performance implications so the next
lecture will be you know how do I
actually paralyze my program and we'll
talk about that